(gentle dramatic music)
- Your olive oil may not
be what it claims to be.
claims to be.
- [Johnny] A couple years
ago in southern Italy
the police were spying on
an organized crime network.
(Person speaking Italian)
- [Johnny] Their undercover footage
shows these large tanker trucks
passing into their compound.
They started tracking
these trucks with GPS
and found that the trucks
were loaded with oil.
They were delivering this oil
to markets and restaurants in Germany.
They were selling it to buyers
who thought that they were buying
high quality extra virgin olive oil
from the best olive regions in the world.
(suspenseful music)
After many months of this investigation
the police finally
busted into the compound
and what they found is
that these criminals
were importing cheap seed oil
that cost them just
over one euro per liter,
but then they were coloring
it with like chlorophyll
to make it look like olive oil.
They even had the machinery
to bottle this oil
and to label it with the important words
extra virgin olive oil
with a nice little Italian flag on it.
At the height of their operation
they were selling around
23,000 liters per week
to customers in the north
for 5 to 10 times the cost
that they bought this cheap seed oil for.
The police estimated that
they were bringing in
around 8 million euros a year.
In the end, 24 people were arrested
and 150,000 liters of fake
olive oil were seized.
(Reporter speaking Italian)
(gentle music)
- Good olive oil is really hard to make.
It's delicate, it's hard
to ship across the world
but when you get the real
stuff, extra virgin olive oil
it's really healthy and delicious.
And from the mafia in southern Italy
to mainstream olive oil brands
on your grocery store shelf
olive oil is full of fraud and deception.
In fact, there's a chance
that you've never actually
tasted extra virgin olive oil,
even if you think you have.
So let me show you how this happened
and why it even matters.
And how you can get in on the real stuff,
real extra virgin olive oil.
'Cause I'm telling you, when
you do, when you taste this,
it's unlike any substance on earth.
(upbeat music)
I've been working out lately,
like I can do 10 pull-ups,
which when I started this
journey like 10 months ago
I could do one, now I can do 10.
and that's because of CoPilot.
CoPilot is this platform
where you get paired up with
a personal fitness coach
and you communicate
with that fitness coach
via a very well designed app.
My coach is named Devyn and he's great
and I've told him all about my goals.
I wanna be able to lift my body,
I want to just have a
workout that's approachable
and not like grueling
and he designed a custom
workout step by step.
So every day when it's time to work out
I open up this app, I press start workout,
it fires it up on my watch and on my phone
and I start working out, I
just follow the instructions.
There's like video
demonstrations of each step
so that it's crystal clear
and then it moves you
on to the next activity.
What this does is, number one
it gives you a real person
to stand accountable to
which is just so much better
than like a YouTube video
that you're like watching
and no one else knows
that you're working out.
CoPilot found that people
are nine times more likely
to stick to a workout routine
if there's a real person
that they have to stand accountable to.
Nine times, which is
actually not that surprising,
it it makes sense.
Number two, it allows you
to customize a workout
exactly to what you want.
Oh, and at the end of every workout
I'm able to give feedback
to my coach Devyn
and be like, "Hey Devyn,
I think it was too easy today on the arms.
Can we make it harder?"
And he the next day has coded in
a new workout that is harder on the arms.
The other thing this does
is it takes away ambiguity.
Like I think the killer of
motivation is ambiguity.
Like you're like, "So
what do I start with?"
And with CoPilot, you just press a button
and it tells you what to start with,
which for me at like six in the morning
when I'm working out because
I need to to be happy,
I don't want to think, I
just want to get it done.
And CoPilot makes that happen
because of its very fancy app.
I try my best to actually use the products
that I endorse here on this channel.
Obviously this is a business,
I need to sponsor these videos
so that we can make good journalism,
but also like I've used this for 10 months
and I can vouch for it, it's
a pretty dang good product.
So there's a link in my description.
It is go.mycopilot.com/Johnny-Harris,
just click the link, it
helps support this channel,
but it also gives you 14 days for free
with your own personal fitness coach.
So that you can design your own workout
and have somebody to stand accountable to
and make those workout
goals actually come true.
Thank you CoPilot for
empowering me to do 10 pull-ups
and for existing and for
sponsoring today's video.
Let's get back to our story
about the mafia and olive oil.
(upbeat music)
Most olive oil in the world is made here
in these sunny climates
of the Mediterranean.
Thousands of years ago,
people here figured out
that juicing the fruit
of this ancient tree
produces a golden oil that's like magic.
They adored this tree.
Its branches were worn
by the goddess of peace
or a victorious olympian.
It was an olive branch
that told Noah that the flood was over.
Over the centuries it became a sacred tree
with a sacred fruit that
produced a sacred liquid.
It was food, it was medicine, it was fuel,
it was a cosmetic, it was a
key part of religious rituals
for people of the Mediterranean
for thousands of years.
The rest of the world didn't know much
about this special oil until the 1960s
when an American doctor was
conducting a health study
of over 13,000 middle aged
men from seven countries.
He found that the people of
Italy and Greece lived longer
and were generally healthier,
despite being ravaged by war and poverty.
He concluded that it must
be because of what they ate,
fish, nuts, vegetables, and, of course,
copious amounts of olive
oil instead of butter.
(upbeat music)
Soon word spread to the rest of the world
that this Mediterranean diet
was the way to live longer
and that olive oil was a key ingredient.
It's the '70s and '80s
and everyone is talking about olive oil.
- Major health headline here tonight
and it involves a very popular diet,
the Mediterranean diet full of olive oil.
- Olive oil.
- Olive oil
- Extra virgin olive oil.
- What is the best olive oil?
- A little olive oil, or
if you like use a lot.
- Between 1958 and 2019,
global production of olive oil tripled.
Demand in the United States exploded.
Olive oil is no longer a regional thing.
By the 1990s this has become
a huge international supply chain
Serving customers around the
world who are willing to pay,
to pay a lot more for this
extra virgin olive oil.
The stuff that scientists was saying
was an elixir of health and longevity.
- You can combine what
is beneficial for health
to what is really taste.
And people, of course, they are quick
to grasp the importance
of combining good food
with good health.
- [Johnny] Suddenly these
small olive oil operations
in rural parts of southern Italy
have international customers
clamoring to get in on their product.
So they start selling
their oil to middlemen
who can take it and sell it to a co-op.
The co-op gets all the oil together
and then sells it to another co-op
who eventually sells it to a company
who bottles it and then ships
it to a far away country
to be put on grocery store shelves.
This complex supply chain
with all these middlemen
comes with a lot of opportunities
for people to take advantage
of this newfound love
for this magical, expensive oil.
But to understand olive oil fraud
you first really have
to understand the magic
of extra virgin olive oil.
(mysterious music)
Every winter at farms
around the Mediterranean
farmers head to their groves
to comb through the branches
of these ancient trees
at just the right time
so that this delicate
fruit is perfectly ripe
as it falls to the ground
carpeting the grove floor.
The clock immediately starts ticking.
Within 24 hours they must
get this precious fruit
to the mill where the olives are crushed
and then spun in a centrifuge
until the oil is separated.
No heat, no filters,
no chemicals, nothing.
Just high quality olives quickly
pressed one time and spun,
then bottled, then crucially
kept dark, kept cool, sealed
and ideally consumed within 18 months.
It's a delicate resource intensive
process to pull this off,
and even more so
when you then have to
ship it across the globe.
But it's really the only way
to get this magical liquid
that we call extra virgin olive oil.
The stuff that's good for your heart,
for your brain, for your bones.
The stuff that tastes
like fatty grassy gold.
This stuff is so good.
And this is where I tell you
that most olive oil is kind of a lie.
Sometimes a white lie
and other times a mafia is
deceiving you kind of lie.
So first things first, Italian
olive oil is important here.
If you look at this price
graph of Italian olive oil
you'll see that it's
quite a bit more expensive
than the olive oil coming
from the other big players
in this space, Spain and Greece.
Italian olive oil is more expensive,
not only because it is
known for genuine quality,
but also because it's Italy.
Italy is Italy, it looks like this.
It's food looks like this.
Italy has the perception
of being the gourmet food
epicenter of the world.
So people, including me,
are willing to pay more
for Italian extra virgin olive oil
because it's good and it's from Italy.
On that point, let me show
you two kind of insane maps.
First look where most
olive oil is made in Italy.
It's the darker areas down here.
And second, let's look
at the regions of Italy
where the mafia is most present.
Right down here next to this
toe and the heel of the boot.
The regions with the highest
production of olive oil
are the regions where the mafia is
and this is where it all comes together.
There's this ancient trading city
right on the toe of the boot.
(gentle dramatic music)
The Calabrian Mafia, one of
Italy's most influential clans
controls this busy port in this city.
They also control or influence
much of the farmland in this
area, including olive groves.
In 2016, this mafia clan was
shipping in cheap, low grade,
chemically treated
olive oil called pumice.
They would then bottle this up
and label it as extra
virgin olive oil from Italy
even though it was like
a derivative of olive oil
chemically treated and not from Italy.
But then they would ship this olive oil
to importers in New York
City, in Boston, in Chicago.
Importers who thought they were buying
the best olive oil in the world
from the best region in the world.
But really they were paying for cheap oil
and giving huge profit margins
to the mafia committing this fraud.
The Italian food police, which
is like literally a thing,
eventually busted this scheme.
- [Reporter] We arrest of
one of the most powerful
street gangs in Calabria.
- Olive oil is hard to detect as fake.
It kind of all looks the same.
You have to have a trained eye
to know if like the color is off.
Most people aren't drinking olive oil,
they're cooking with it or
putting it on their salad
and they're kind of just
assuming that it's legitimate
and that it's giving them health benefits.
And a lot of people don't really know
what good olive oil tastes like.
So olive oil fraud is particularly easy.
And particularly lucrative,
because of the premium price
that good extra virgin olive oil commands.
Because of this Italy has
an entire investigative unit
dedicated to food fraud,
and they're regularly
busting these fraud schemes.
Some of them are less extreme
than the ones we've talked about.
A really common one is people will ship in
olive oil from Spain, they
will bottle it in Italy
and then they will put a label
that says that it's Italian olive oil
and they will sell it at a higher premium
because Italian olive oil
commands a higher price.
But oftentimes it's even
more subtle than that.
Olive oil companies will
mix extra virgin olive oil
with old or decaying oil
or they'll use olives
that have been sitting
on the floor of the grove
for like a couple of weeks
and they're like, eh, we will
just like press them anyway
and call it extra virgin olive oil.
And it's not, it's a different thing.
Again, this is a really
complex supply chain
with lots of opportunities
for people to step in
and change it from this delicate liquid
called extra virgin olive
oil to something else,
and it's really hard to detect.
A lot of this olive oil ends
up on your supermarket shelf
with a photo of a humble Italian farmer
in an idyllic landscape
with words like cold pressed
or premium selection with
pretend stamps of approval
that don't mean anything.
I mean listen,
these could all be legit
extra virgin olive oils
but I don't know because here in the US
we actually have no enforcement standards.
Luckily scientists have tested this.
One of the first big tests on this
was from researchers at UC
Davis, a college in California.
They went out and bought
a bunch of olive oil
from stores in California.
They tested them to see
if they met the standards
for extra virgin olive oil
and they found that 69%
of imported olive oil
that was claiming to be extra virgin
failed to meet the
internationally recognized
sensory standards where
an expert tastes it
and can tell if it's
actually extra virgin or not.
And of those 31% failed to
meet the chemical standards,
meaning they were too acidic.
A lot of this stuff is not
extra virgin olive oil.
Now I'm sure I'm gonna get an email
from people in the olive oil industry
saying that this study
isn't actually legit
because it was only a sample size
of olive oil in stores in California.
But this was actually just
one of several studies
over the years that have
shown the same thing.
Most of the olive oil on our shelves
claiming to be that amazing golden liquid
that is delicately produced and stored
and contains the fullness of the taste
and the health benefits of olives,
AKA extra virgin olive oil,
most of these labels are lying.
Now most of the oil in these
bottles does come from olives.
Like there's not a lot of that fraud
where they're like taking seed oil
and pretending that it's olive oil
that's been clamped down on.
Still happens, but not very often.
But again, it being made from olives
is not what makes extra
virgin olive oil special.
It is the way that it's made.
It's the way that it's processed.
It's how quickly they take
the fruit from the grove
and they press it and bottle
it and store it and ship it.
This oil is not that.
It is not extra virgin anymore.
And yet they slap a
label so that you and I
feel like we're getting the best stuff
and we're getting it for a good price.
You would be in big
trouble if you got caught
labeling it as such in Italy
and a lot of European countries.
But wait, why haven't these companies
who are doing it in the United
States gotten in trouble?
Because in America we don't care.
Whereas in Italy they literally
have laws that are violated
when you label something
as extra virgin olive oil
and it's not.
Here in the US, we have no laws for this.
Companies don't have
to test their olive oil
to prove that it's extra virgin.
They can just import them
and slap on extra virgin to the label
and no one can do anything about it.
Between this and the
fact that most Americans
probably don't know
what extra virgin olive
oil even takes like
so they don't know what to expect.
The US has become what one expert calls
the dumping grounds for olive oil
that says it's extra virgin and it's not.
So is there any hope here?
Can you ever try the real stuff
extra virgin olive oil that
is like magical golden liquid?
Yes you can.
It exists.
You just need to know what to look for.
We put together a list of tips
on how you can find legitimate
extra virgins olive oil
and know that you're
getting the good stuff.
I'm gonna put the link in the description.
It's everything from the material
that the bottle is made out of
to the nuances in the
packaging and labeling
and the date labeling, the quality seals.
We also give you some ideas
on some of the trickery
that companies try to fake it
to try to make it look
legit but it's actually not.
So that link is in a description.
If you want to try extra virgin olive oil
and get your hands on it and
are willing to pay for it
because spoiler alert it is more expensive
than the fake stuff that's
pretending to be real,
then you can go check out that doc
and hopefully it's helpful.
The point is that it is possible
and I guess if you're still
here watching this video
you're wondering why is this so important?
Like why are we talking about
oil and olive oil fraud?
And there are a couple answers.
Number one is that this is a
really amazing old tradition.
It's a tradition that
fueled the civilizations
in the Mediterranean
for thousands of years.
The harvesting and pressing
and bottling and consumption
of olive oil, good olive oil
is an old delicate tradition.
And when you mix capitalism with that
you often get a race to the the bottom
on who can make it the cheapest
and sell it for the cheapest
so that they can make the most money.
And inevitably you will get
opportunistic people who try to trick you
to make you think that it's the real thing
so that you'll pay for it.
And this hurts the producers
who are actually doing the
resource intensive process
of harvesting and processing
this in the right way.
And at the end of the day, to
me, it is absolutely worth it.
Good extra virgin olive oil
is unlike anything else.
A few years ago I discovered
that I had never actually
tasted extra virgin olive oil.
So I bought my first bottle.
It was kind of expensive, it was like $25
and I started using it on everything.
I even started drinking it raw
just to like get the flavor
because I'm kind of weird
and that's what I do
and I'm sorry, but it's just delicious.
And I started to understand
why this stuff became so sacred
for so many cultures in the Mediterranean.
Why it's like a part of
every major religion.
Why it has endured as a
health and culinary staple.
And I guess in knowing how
valuable this liquid is
I actually understand why fraudsters
and the mafia got involved here,
why they tried to deceive us
into thinking that we are consuming
the most magical liquid on
earth, even if we're not.
(upbeat music)
Thanks for watching the video.
Am I too obsessed with olive oil?
Is that a thing?
Because I'm, I just really like it
and I just had to make this video
because I just am like I think this video
was me being obsessed with olive oil
and also me being so frustrated
at when the international
economy like screws us over
with opportunistic corporations.
Like those two things coming
together is what this video is.
So thank you for watching.
I hope you get in
on the the how to buy good olive oil doc
that we put together in the description.
I wanna thank those who support
us over at The Newsroom,
which is our Patreon.
We obviously do
sponsorships for our videos,
which is a major way that
we're able to do these.
But in addition, The Newsroom
has become a community of
people who wanna support
the independent journalism
we're doing here
and I'm deeply appreciative of that.
Over on The Newsroom,
you can get access to a
behind the scenes vlog
that we do every month that
introduces you to the team
shows you what we're up
to, how we do what we do,
just sort of gives you
a behind the scenes.
And then you also get
access to my scripts.
You get access to Tom
Fox music if you want
but more importantly you get access
to the warm fuzzy feeling
that you are supporting
independent journalism on YouTube.
So I think that's why most
people subscribe to The Newsroom,
is because it is supporting
this kind of work.
Other ways you can support,
we've got LUTs and Presets,
which are how we color
our videos and our photos.
I made a map poster that I really like.
That's super cool and fun.
And if you have purchased it,
please tag me on Instagram
so you can show me what it
looks like in your room.
We launched a new channel
that's probably a huge thing
I should have said first.
Search Party is a new
channel that is live now.
We launched it with my
old colleague from Vox,
Sam Ellis, the creator of Vox Atlas.
He now has his own channel
and it is in collaboration with us
and we are all working
together now and it's awesome.
So Search Party is live.
I think those are all the
things I need to tell you
here in this little end part of the video.
I'm looking forward to
hearing your thoughts
and your comments.
I always appreciate the back and forth
and the dialogue and the
feedback, so keep that up.
And thank you CoPilot for,
for sponsoring today's video.
Thank you all for being here.
I'll see you in the next one.
(gentle music)